hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today I want to talk about why English
spelling is so damn weird damn with a
silent in English is well known for its
chaotic and seemingly unpredictable
spelling how do you think you say this
word it's fish here we have [ __ ] as in
rough e as in women and sure as in
nation well okay that's not really how
fish is spelled but you get the point
sometimes gh sounds like fun
sometimes Oh sounds like it and
sometimes TI sounds like sha the famed
British philologist William Walter skeet
once said no one can tell how to
pronounce an English word unless he has
at some time or other heard it I guess
that's like the time I refer to the
Pyrenees Mountains as paren ease a
region that spans the Spain France
border in the westernmost Perini's
mountains a learner of English or a
young native speaker seeing this word
for the first time might read it as
indict but it's actually indict and once
they learned that this word is
pronounced rough they might pronounce
this word as so rough but it's thorough
or thorough for people who already use
these words at speech then reading them
is not much of a problem but I doubt
they'll always be able to spell them
when writing doubt why is English
spelling like this when so many other
languages have systematic spelling that
corresponds with pronunciation well many
other languages have undergone a
spelling reform to clean up their own
inconsistencies while English has never
really undergone that type of spelling
reform so modern English spelling
continues to be a product of its history
1,300 years of history the vocabulary of
English consists of four major words
dogs a Germanic Corps mainly from
anglo-saxon but also from Old Norse
French including both Norman French and
Parisian French Latin and Greek these
four word stocks all have different
spelling systems English spelling has
had its complications right from the
start when the anglo-saxons first began
writing in the Latin alphabet rather
than their runic alphabet there weren't
enough individual letters to represent
all of the sounds of Old English
so some letters represented more than
one sound and some non-latin letters
were used nowadays many of us tend to
think of written English as the basis of
English but back in those days it was
seen as merely a representation of
speech so there was a lot of dialectal
variation that was reflected in spelling
in the same word was often spelled in
various ways even by the same person
this situation continued through the
Middle English period and even into the
early modern English period Shakespeare
even spelled his own name in several
different ways but let's go back to
Middle English for a minute
English entered the Middle English
period with the Norman Conquest when the
Norman french-speaking rulers had a
tremendous impact on the language many
many French words were adopted into
English in large part keeping their
French spelling even though the sounds
and stress patterns changed to match the
English language so there's a bigger
which is probably Germanic and there's
figure from the French word Figaro there
is bridge and there's marriage from
French maquillage we have the Germanic
word sit with an S and we have the
French lone word city with a see because
in French C is pronounced before II and
I similarly there's the Germanic word
kill and the French lone word cell
changes to the spelling of existing
words were also made by Norman scribes
who preferred French spelling
conventions the sound as in church used
to be written with the letter C
but the Normans began using CH since at
the time CH represented Chuck in French
that changed and CH came to represent
the sound sure so there are additional
words borrowed from French in more
recent centuries that feature the show
sound like champagne and Chateau you'll
also see spelled TCH
after short vowels as in catch and Dutch
but as always in English there are
exceptions like much and such Norman
scribes also changed the spelling of qua
from C W to qu so the word Kuenn meaning
Queen was originally spelled like this
but became spelled like this even though
qu was already pronounced
in Parisian French at that time the qua
pronunciation existed in anglo-norman
the Norman French dialect that had
developed in England so some French
loanwords in particular those from
anglo-norman feature the quartz ound
like question and equal but later
Parisian French grew an influence while
anglo-norman faded and French borrowings
from that time onward featured the cut
sound like etiquette and there are many
words like this that historically never
had a qua cell but are spelled with qu
because that's how cut is now most
commonly written in French physique
unique key lacquer they introduced the
oh you spelling of the sound ooh so
who's the word for house began to be
spelled with oh you closer to the modern
spelling this also happened to the word
mousse meaning Mouse they also changed
the letter U - OH in some cases when it
was followed by V N or M because in
cursive writing it looked too similar to
those letters so now we have words like
[ __ ]
some love and Sun in which o represents
the short u sound ah but this spelling
didn't fully catch on so we also have
words like dumb drum etc the main thing
to remember is that the anglo-norman s--
made a number of changes and additions
to english spelling that sometimes
clashed with other ways of spelling the
great vowel shift in the printing press
the biggest changes to English
pronunciation took place between the
years of 1350 and 1700 in a process
called the great vowel shift which
spanned the transition from late Middle
English to early modern English and into
the modern English period for reasons
that are not exactly clear all the long
vowels of Middle English shifted ah as
in nom became ah as in nem which then
shifted to F as in nem and then shifted
to a as an named a as in swetha shifted
to e as in sweet ah as in gret shifted
to a as in great e as in team shifted to
IE as in time and shifted further to I
as in time o as in boat shifted to ooh
as in boot aw as in bought shifted to o
as in boat ooh
as in whose shifted to
Oh as in house and then owl as in house
you might be thinking okay so the sounds
changed they must have updated the
spelling to match the new sounds right
wrong during the 1400s and 1500s English
spelling became more standardized due to
the arrival of the printing press in
England so English spelling was
essentially frozen in time and English
spelling today in large part reflects
the pronunciation of middle english from
hundreds of years ago the fate of
English spelling lay in the hands of a
very small number of people specifically
the owners of printing presses their
staff and authors there was no
regulatory agency no committee offering
suggested Spelling's or anything like
that
authors submitted their works and the
printers produced the final text that
would be printed and they could pretty
much do whatever they wanted with the
spelling William Caxton brought the
first printing press to England in 1476
after running one in Belgium the Flemish
typesetters he brought with him to
England changed the spelling of some
words to match the spelling conventions
of Flemish this is why there's an H in
the words ghost and ghastly those are
just a couple of words but printers and
their staff made countless decisions
about which variant Spelling's to use or
use their own spellings and over the
fifteenth and sixteenth centuries
standard spelling gradually arose based
mainly on the London variety of English
some odd things happened in the process
sometimes the spelling of a word came
from one dialect while its pronunciation
came from another the words one and once
use East Midlands spelling but southern
pronunciation the word busy uses West
Midlands spelling but East Midlands or
London pronunciation and the word Barry
has West Midlands spelling but Kentish
pronunciation but the biggest
generalization we can make about the
printers is that they favored
conservative Spelling's and they ignored
the changes of the great vowel shift and
it wasn't only vowels that were shifting
during that time some consonants were
disappearing from words but they
continued to be written the k' in the
word knife for example it used to be
pronounced Knuth and how about the word
night it has a silent K and the silent
GH Kaneesha
the Norman scribes had written two
sounds ha and ha with the digraph GH
the palatal sound disappeared while the
hot sound disappeared or turned into fuh
the word light comes from Middle English
leashed you can still hear that
consonant in the German cognate least
Knight comes from Middle English niched
one word with the [ __ ] sound is laughs
which comes from Middle English loja
there's a common word in modern English
that features a silent gh even though it
never had a ha or ha sound the word
delight in Middle English it was Delita
it was Rhys pelled to resemble the word
light another type of intentional
tweaking of English spelling took place
reselling words based on their etymology
for example the word doubt was duta in
Middle English the word debt was debt or
debt both words entered English from
French without a B but they were respect
to resemble their Latin words of origin
du bateau de de beaten in diet was in
Deaton in Middle English the C was added
to match its Latin word of origin in
dicto the word Isle was ela with no s in
Middle English this word originally came
from French but then was respec to match
a respess then that Rhys pelling was
also mistakenly applied to the word
island which was island in Middle
English even though it doesn't share the
same etymology as Isle another example
of a mistaken Rhys pelling occurs with
the word ending MB the B and the word
dumb for example used to be pronounced
but then became silent while it remained
in writing but some other words ending
in M were mistakenly respect to end with
MB such as the word limb some more
examples are crumb numb thumb etc
because some words had an etymological B
that wasn't pronounced people could no
longer tell when a bee was needed based
on the sound of the word this resulted
in hyper correction adding the letter to
words where it wasn't necessary it may
seem like these scholars made
self-indulgent unnecessary changes but I
guess they all became part of the story
of English the last big shake-up to
English spelling came during the
Renaissance period when English took in
many new loan words
from French Latin Greek and other
European languages many of them of a
more academic nature the reason for this
was the need for a new vocabulary for
all the new concepts in the emerging
fields of science medicine and the arts
and increased interest in Latin and
Greek literature encouraged the
borrowing a few examples from this new
wave of vocabulary are epitome vignette
repertoire amateur camouflage anesthesia
decorum notorious chlorine and the word
Renaissance itself which comes from the
French word meaning rebirth
since then smaller numbers of loanwords
from numerous other languages have
continued to flow into English often
retaining their original spelling or a
transliteration of it or at least an
approximation of it there's the Japanese
word karaoke the Polynesian word tattoo
the Spanish word aficionado the Chinese
word kowtow and many other words that
may have forced you to rely on your
iPhone's autocorrect function which is
never a safe bet some people might say
that all of these historical influences
on English spelling enrich the language
and make it more fascinating while
others might say that English spelling
is a mess and a major pain in the butt I
generally tend to think that it enriches
the language until I make a spelling
mistake seen by a million people in a
video like this then it's a major pain
in the butt if you enjoyed this video be
sure to check out the various Lancaster
accounts like YouTube Facebook Instagram
and Twitter and once again thank you to
all of my wonderful patreon supporters
especially these ones right here on the
screen because they are my top tier of
patreon supporters so many extra special
thanks to them and to everyone thank you
for watching and have a nice day
[Music]